ivanov bon choix
vous visez
[Applaudissements]
aja prend vie
pas trop mon but
il est en train de devenir star c'est
vrai mais quand même alors je disais
dans le sommaire de cette émission un
prénom de coiffeur et un nom de votre
cas vous dites vous dans les rayons la
ivanoff c'est celle qui est tout en bas
elle coûte 90 centimes d'euro souvent
elle est à côté du destop c'est le même
logo une tête de mort
c'est vrai et 20 nov
dans le regard alors vous avez commencé
par le théâtre d'improvisation à 11 12
ans chez papy attrape tout à fait votre
père vous a dit tu veux faire le malin à
l'école bah tu vas aller faire le malin
sur scène c'est ça ce que j'aime c'est
le bas et là vous découvrez que vous
avez un disons le don pour être con
je vois que j'ai certaines facilités
ouais mais c'est bien cesser c'est
exactement ce que macron a dit à
castaner samedi soir dont pourrait être
conclu y'avait pas le seul alors papy
donc alias alain degois c'est la filière
djamel ouais on vous retrouve jamel
comedy club dans cette forme
d'expression théâtrale qui permet de
monter sur scène en tee shirt et en
basket qu'on appelle le stand-up vous
faites du stand-up
c'est très bien ensuite on vous découvre
au cinéma dans un excellent film de
grand corps malade qui savaient le
patient oui ensuite il ya le sens de la
fête de nakache et toledano évidemment
et puis le grand bain gilles lellouche
comme cat et quelques millions d'entrées
et là effectivement vous commencez à
être connu et on dit de vous que vous
êtes le nouveau jacques villeret je suis
assez d'accord avec ça bah ce gentil cui
connu je sais pas mais en tout cas de
d'avoir plus de faire plus de deux films
et où je m'éclate en mieux et c'est cool
là vous allez avoir un triomphe
profitez-en
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on continue avec sopi parce qu'un
artiste c'est aussi un code barre
[Musique]
alban ivanov re bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
dans ma biche et là
alors on avait tout à l'heure votre
irrésistible ascension et vous êtes ici
ce soir pour votre premier premier rôle
et voilà
le film s'appelle walter hill et réalisé
par va renter fujian alors le pitch est
une équipe de bras cassés qui montrent
un casse dans un supermarché le problème
c'est que le vigile est un ancien chef
de guerre africains qui va leur faire
vivre l'enfer toute la nuit super pic
super idée le vigile s'est issaka
sawadogo sawadogo voilà et sa femme
c'est judith el zein tout à fait le film
super ben merci beaucoup et c'est voilà
ce qui est intéressant aussi avec judith
des gens qui sont pas du même milieu on
va dire au cinéma avec les des gains une
connexion par et marseille voilà c'était
un peu l'idée de faire un peu c'est trop
long le truc
c'est que le film a été tourné deux
nuits pendant 38 dans un supermarché
mais qui leur ont mis des vigiles sur le
cul pour voir qui piquent pas détruit
c'est vrai ça commence au début c'est un
la légende du cinéma et tout et après
finalement c'est bon même si vous faites
du sida on va quand même vous surveiller
ouais franchement ils ont eu raison
déjà impliqué des trucs qu'on ne peut
pas s'empêcher ne serait ce que des
chips là des chiffres des bonbons des
trucs qu'on n'a jamais goûté voilà du pq
on a fait aussi
pour vous alban sans rôle de composition
parce que goran le personnage du film
c'est une crapule sans foi ni loi alors
que vous êtes plutôt cool dans la vie
c'est vrai c'est vrai que c'était ce
n'était pas forcément le truc le plus
simple de jouer tout le temps énervé
mais voilà moi j'ai composé de sérieux
moi je suis un acteur donc je compose
deadpool dans la vie oui vous aimez des
gens oui magnéto serge
je voulais souhaiter une bonne fête à
tous les musulmans eid mubarak et j'ai
envie de vous dire c'est pas parce que
vous êtes demuslim que vous n'êtes pas
des jambons
province et
[Applaudissements]
celle là elle est pas dans le bouquin
cela
c'est pas parce que vous êtes des noms
j'en vois déplorant un va te l'expliquer
après alors à décortiquer alors vous
avez dit c'est un bon film de google bah
c'est comme ça que nous on justifie
notre notre humour en singles de gogol
donc on a fait un bon film un bon film
de gogol voilà en relevant le spectacle
qui vous a fait connaître sa plaie
élément perturbateur on va faire une
interwiew élément perturbateur
[Musique]
j'avoue pertur de vous appeler alban
non
ça vous perturbe est reconnue dans la
rue non
non non non pas des jambons
oui nous aurons
alors les sons du jeu de boules c'est ce
qui m'a fait quand même un jour je
souhaite en russe fort le dit laurent tu
connais jean rochefort jean on tue le
rang jean rochât nom et l'autre camp il
masque et tuba parce qu'ils se
proclament pour un peu normal j'en
reçois et laurent du samu 20 minutes il
fait beau ce fort gênant lors roche mais
je connais pas
ça vous perturbe quand on vous demande
un sel fille alors que vous avez la tête
dans le cul ouais
ça c'est le plus dur ça ouais ça vous
perturbe quand on vous dit ouais t'as
comique toi et vas-y fais nous rires non
mais j'ai
l'impression d'avoir le hockey
c'est au père tire quand vous avez
quelque part et qu'on vous propose de la
vodka à cause de vos origines russes oh
non pas du tout
ça me fait plus chier qu'on me propose
de los angeles
est
elle pertinente psg c'est emilie en
ligue des champions ouais bah oui c'est
ce que c'est ce qu'on attend du psg que
ça existe en ligue des champions qu'est
ce qu'il faut faire bah c'est la bonne
c'est la bonne question c gepa j'ai pas
la reine est ce qu'il faut virer nasser
non bah je pense pas apprécié on verra
la serpe et le psg va ressembler à dijon
sûrement
ouais ben c'est quoi rien ne sert
de les perdre mes cheveux bon bah j'en
veux tu fais une adresse très bien
largement de quoi que bâton
ça vous perturbe quand on vous demande
bilité jacques chirac à barbe ce jeu me
fait très mal donc à l'asie pour voir sa
ug jacques chirac
ce qu'il faut dire c'est beau le faisait
quand vous étiez petit pourquoi c'est ça
c'était bas quand il était président au
cas où il choisirait même
si jacques chirac maintenant ce qui fait
ça vous perturbe quand une meuf ne
répond pas très rapidement à vos textos
ça dépend de cqi ouais ouais ça a
démontré qu'il a pu
c'est l'image chip
hâlé deux
voyages un couple secret j'ai perdu
quand vous n'arrivez pas à atteindre
l'orgasme en même temps que votre
partenaire a déjà budget ordinaire des
habitants qui ne répond pas
et vous avez été ensemble j'ai
l'impression que ça perturbe plus ma
partenaire seulement j'ai que tu jouais
à vous même temps que moi ou pas ouah
moi ça va je suis bien chaud
j'ai perdu un combat parfait des 22 cul
non pas moi mais ça a perturbé des fois
mes potes et ouais parce que votre mère
vous testez vos sketches aux vêtements
non huawei ma mère est là elle a un
franc parler ou à oujda
une petite anecdote au collège et avec
une copine dans ma chambre ma mère qui
crie de la cuisine tu as quand même pas
de faire sucer
la plus belle oui rappelons sa mère
c'est quoi son prénom catherine
le parent
ta maman
maman la mouche avec laurent baffie il
veut te parler
bon bah tant pis pour moi je vous je
vous embrasse moi
oui c'est moi [ __ ] tu me crois
oui on est payé pour ça
je voulais vous féliciter
catherine pour votre site porno qui est
vraiment bien foutu
[Applaudissements]
ça vous perturbe la ville qui fait débat
non pas du tout palazio heureusement il
ya encore laurent baffie à la télé
[Applaudissements]
pour être sûr nous hydrater le lino
lardy tube abonnez vous il mettait un
peu de bleu